it's great to be joined today by Mary
speedo who is the CEO of seek spelled
see e e K Mary this is a super
interesting project to me because I've
been following so in general in the
music world we're aware of you know the
top tier artists that have the major
touring deals and sell a ton of albums
and streaming revenue and all of this
stuff but for the vast majority of
musical artists they have quite frankly
pretty bad deals when it comes to online
streaming revenue and also can find it
pretty difficult to even monetize
touring which increasingly in the music
industry is sort of how you make money
so the idea would seek is through a VR
virtual reality headset which is already
for sale at Amazon and Target and Best
Buy you can participate in concerts
through virtual reality which is sort of
like a completely scalable way for
artists to monetize what they're doing
so first talk about like what's the the
fundamental problem that you're trying
to solve and then we'll talk about how
you're going about it okay so we're
solving two major problems one is
scaling content right specifically
touring sports events just think about
any type of content as you mention
production costs are increasingly
getting more and more you know expensive
as well
there is the geographical limitation
even for those artists that can do 100
venues and you know we've heard recently
of artists like Guns and Roses selling
out a million tickets at 24 hours right
and they just physically you know just
keep adding more so that's one of the
major problems of resulting is virtual
reality allows you to scale what
otherwise would have geographically been
eliminates the other aspect which is a
major issue that we're solving is by
authenticating content distribution
access on the blockchain we're able to
actually do payments to the content
owners
you know when it comes to content rights
you might have one song that will have
four to five people that own it so a lot
of times what happens is not everyone
gets paid when that piece of music or a
piece of content is consumed but now
with the blockchain you're able to get
that absolute transparency and most
importantly get content on is paid for
their hard work so a musical artist
conceivably could do a virtual reality
event it could be a live event or a
pre-recorded event is that right is it
flexible in that way
yeah that's flexible in that way and the
other thing that we've done - is it
could actually be just even 2d content
so we want to remove any friction from
people accessing content so it's virtual
realities of materiality it's mixed
reality and it's also 2d content in
immersive environments I'm sort of
thinking of like the you know for me the
environment is a major thing and we talk
about climate change on our program all
the time I'm starting to think about
when you take this out of entertainment
and maybe put it in education whether
it's training on procedures for example
for medical doctors right just as like
one example or so many other
possibilities isn't there the
possibility of there being a huge sort
of environmental play here as well if
you don't need for example to fly a
thousand doctors halfway around the
world or across the country to
participate in some kind of training but
it could be done via virtual reality in
this way that seems like a major
possibility to me yeah absolutely so in
addition speed by mental factor there's
also even the safety factor right
because today there are a lot of you
know threats all around and so more and
more people are staying at home to
consume content and through VR through
these immersive environments they're
actually able to be there I said they're
actually there yeah and I think we could
argue about you know the broader
societal question as to whether that's
good or not but there's no question that
it's a reality in the technology that's
available makes it possible to
participate remotely and so many of
these things what about when it comes to
education have you thought about the
applications here in terms of education
I mean years ago when I did my MBA I did
an online class where I would basically
join the class via a webcam and I had
like a pretty terrible view of what was
what was going on in the classroom it
seems that the next step there could
also potentially be virtual reality
absolutely I think that education is
actually going to be the greatest
contribution that virtual reality makes
to the world because humans are virtual
you know we're all visual learners
so we you know there studies that have
proven that when you learn through
virtual reality of creating a memory and
the mind doesn't have the ability to
distinguish between what's real and
what's not
so you're it's the most organic way to
experience knowledge and we're you know
seeing tremendous tremendous peace and
balance in terms of the kind of
education where actually we teamed up
with oculus they're funding a study that
we're doing on the learning outcomes for
education they've got you know other
schools involved Harvard John Hopkins
and the list goes on and we're looking
at the you know impact of virtual
reality for educational outcomes yeah I
mean our tests have have there been a B
studies done that compare learning
retention for example comparing being
physically in the classroom joining via
webcam and joining via virtual reality
because that that seems like it would be
fascinating to get data from yeah
there's you know data out there may be
testing that's been done in terms of
looking at recalled so we called for
someone reading about a subject in a
book and a week later only being able to
retain about 20% compared to
experiencing it in VR and a year later
being able to retain eighty percent so
there's just so much in terms of in for
the potential for education yeah I'm
really actually interested in looking at
more brain studies in terms of how
consuming via VR differs in the brain
from other types of media or
audio-visual consumption we looked at so
audio books have become a made
your business and also just in general a
major part of the reading that's done at
least in the United States and the
studies that I've looked at and we've
interviewed experts about this seem to
suggest that the brain sort of
assimilates data very similarly when you
listen to an audiobook assuming of
course that you're not like in a wildly
distracting environment compared to when
you're you're actually just reading the
book in the sort of old-fashioned
traditional way and that my guess is
that in the next five years we're gonna
learn a ton about what goes on in the
brain when participating in virtual
reality as well and you know how much of
that research is already taking place
there's you know there's quite a bit
going on you know especially for
three-minute ovie is the fact that
people are able to eventually using
virtual reality and they can actually
get rid of phobias just by you know
being in virtual environments and so
they're you know quite a bit it's not as
much but there are some you know
experiments that are going on and some
studies that are going on
I saw a military study where you know
they applied the art to burn victims and
they found that the VR was more
effective than even morphine you know so
cocaine treatment so quite a bit of
studies going on in terms of how we can
apply in VR to everyday life so I want
to talk about the the tokenization in a
moment but before we get to that as far
as the events right will is the plan
that the events will always be
centralized like for example a concert
that people can join via virtual reality
or a medical training session that
people can join via VR or could there be
a direction that's more of a
decentralized YouTube creators with the
equipment and infrastructure to deliver
content to seek audiences directly or is
that not a direction you're thinking of
going in no it's a direction I mean we
want to decentralize the ability to
offer content to people who are looking
for content so we're all about
frictionless access to content which
means that we want to enable
content creator to be able to reach the
content consumer directly so it's this
whole aspect of decentralizing being
able to do this and we're doing this not
only through the platform which allows
that he wants to upload content and get
it to the owner and could directly
authenticate the content and do the
rights management so we're also doing
that through Studio so we're going to be
opening around the world for people to
do exactly that so let's talk about the
token I mean one of the one of the
questions I always like to ask whenever
we're talking to a project that is
tokenizing is what is the benefit of
tokenizing what purpose does the token
serve and how are you sort of conceiving
that yes so we initially looked at
organization not from the crypto
perspective but from a ease-of-use
perspective when you're in a virtual
environment the worst thing that you
have to do is you take off your headset
which breaks the sense of presence so we
wanted even to be able to buy points and
then be able to consume content using
points so that was the first step
towards tokenization that we did and we
have these C tokens right there were not
crypto token so they were just into
tokens and then the other aspect is we
wanted to have a way to bring more
transparency to the payments system
because the biggest issue that everybody
complains about in the industry is the
fact that any look as a content creator
XYZ service can play my music you know
ten million times and then say it was
only a hundred times so I really don't
know how many times they played it but
now for the first time what the seats
open allows you to do is really
authentic in that access really
authenticate that this has actually been
consumed the other aspect is digital and
physical merchandise so now the artists
can also create digital merchandise they
can create physical merchandise which
will also authenticate on the blockchain
and then just every time you use the C
tokens were able to not only make the
payments but we're also able to
identity that these are you know exactly
what they are
so the token will be used not only for
individual consumers to purchase the
content that they want to see or events
they want to participate in it will also
be the token in which the creator's will
be paid and that can also apply to
digital and physical merchandise do I
have that correctly okay oh no I'm sorry
I was my follow-up to that was what
would it cost as a creator to produce
one of these virtual events in order to
so it could be anywhere someone I'm
doing an interview back in the course
where they have the camera where it
caught cotton you know whatever their
timer to a very you know extravagant
concert right such as what we would do
with our partners you know some music
who were partnered with that could so
could range anywhere from you know a few
thousands of dollars all the way to
notice the dollars depending on the
content in other words the cost of being
on the platform itself is actually not
really the big cost it's the the event
production cost which you would incur
regardless of whether you're on the seat
platform exactly as far as the token
sale can you just give us a sort of
general timeline and sense of where
things are um so basically we're done
with the token sale and we're a thankful
for everyone who seem enthusiastic about
bringing this concept to life we you
know got the tremendous contributions
which are very excited about and so now
where we are we're listed on exchanges
and you have more exchanges that are
coming and so that's where we are now
where you know for those who missed the
token sale tickets so pick some up on
the various exchanges and we're working
on setting up the studios or working on
with our partners to create amazing
content from you know in a month or so
your
to see probably a major artists you know
talking about a seed head side creating
content so we're very excited about the
Apple look and everything that's coming
a real big object that is doing things
very very exciting Mary Speedos the CEO
of seek that's Cee K and you can find
out more at Cee K dot-com Mary
congratulations and I really look
forward to following the progress of the
project thank you thank you so much for
having me